[Music]
there is a lot of news today regarding
the DC EU and the MCU and we'll start
with this first video on Aquaman
Entertainment Weekly has done a great
job as always at showing us awesome new
pictures of our favorite heroes and
that's what they did today will they
give us a first look at Aquaman mera and
Queen atlanna
this is an exclusive first look and it's
also our first time seeing Nicole Kidman
as Queen atlanna I think they look
really great and they get me really
excited about a few things the first are
the suits I really like the suits of
mirror and Queen atlanna I really like
the design and how it kind of looks like
gills one thing I really like about Mira
suit is that it's staying pretty true to
her character suit in the comics and
Queen Atlanta suit seems to be taken
from the animated version of Queen
Atlanta and I think they both look just
really really great and then you have
Arthur curry or the Aquaman in just
regular clothes and you can see on the
next magazine cover he's just in a tank
top and I really like this because I
think it means that they're going to
show us a decent amount of footage of
him out of the water one thing that I
really love particularly are the colors
it's bright it's vibrant it's very
colorful and even Aquaman in the middle
he's wearing all dark clothes but it's
still kind of colorful this is something
that DC has just been really bad at is
the color scheme of all their movies
that they do they're way too dark and I
get it the comics are dark but the
movies are way too dark especially in
the Justice League at the end scene when
they're fighting Steppenwolf I I just
felt like it was just not done well it
was way too dark to animation was really
bad and that's how a lot of the DC
movies have been and it's good that
they're changing it because I think
it'll make a huge difference and it
seems like we're about to see an actual
trailer for Aquaman usually when things
like this happen when a movie gets the
cover of a huge magazine
means a trailer is shortly following we
could even get it today possibly
tomorrow there has been rumors that it
is going to drop this week so be on the
lookout so that's it for the exclusive
first look let me know your thoughts on
these what do you think about their
suits what do you think about the colors
what do you think about Aquaman being a
normal clothes let me know all of that
in the comments below don't forget to
hit that like button and subscribe to my
channel to stay up to date on Aquaman DC
Marvel and all things superhero thank
you so much for watching
wolf wolf
[Music]